[Musique]
nous on s'occupe des ennemis du reich
des enfants juifs
une fois qu'ils arrivent ici benjamin et
fait passer clandestinement en espagne
par les montagnes là bas ils sont en
sécurité
mes hommes et moi seront postés à lescun
pour faire en sorte qu'aucun français ou
juifs en fuite
le traverse les montagnes vers l'espagne
les gens voient ce qu'ils veulent voir
son bien trop paresseux pour chercher
autre chose quand on voit un homme boire
avant midi pense que c'est un ivrogne
par l'époux qui sous tend une vieille
femme en noir pense que si tu ne veux
pas une sainte
douvrin garçons les bras ap la
commission on pense que c'est un
coursier par un héros
si à un moment donné je me retrouve face
à eux je n'en mènerait au moins avec moi
[Musique]